[Music]
Gentlemen, good morning.  I'm interviewing you
today for a website called
Serview.  I would have liked to have
your opinion on the concept of
cyberwarfare by cyberpai.  What
can you tell us about that?
I can start there.  We've been
bombarded for years with this
concept of cyberwarfare which corresponds to
a form of militarization of
the Internet.
Infrastructure deployment.  We are thinking of
AMS6's toy, the Deep Packet Inspection of
legislative provisions to give
offensive powers in matters of
cyberattack now in France to LANs
and institutions worldwide
.  It's
public procurement that's going with contracts worth
I don't know how many zeros for the
same companies that sell
missiles and fighter jets.
The problem is that when we talk about
cyberwar, we talk about the internet as a
battlefield, we talk about
troop movements, we just forget one
parameter which is the citizen.  And for
years, we were sold a vision
of security, of cybersecurity
called cybergre, in which
citizens were simply forgotten.  And
today, with
Snowden's revelation, we realize the
NSA's Bullrun program, which aims
to actively sabotage, one by one, all
commercial technologies for
protecting our
communication data.  We are realizing today that we
all have a spy in our pocket.
Could you elaborate a little bit on
the chandelier program?  Beyond
the various
NSA programs, we see the failure of
cybersecurity policies.
The only thing it was used for was
contracts for a
military-industrial complex that will need to be
renamed, I don't know, the
digital military-industrial complex or something
like that.  While no one has thought about
developing cyberpeace.
Cyberpeace is based on the definition of
peace.  Peace is a state in which
one is free from the fear of
aggression.  What would it
mean in the digital environment to be
free from the fear of aggression?  It
means putting the citizen at the heart of
security.  It means putting the
citizen at the heart of technology.  It
means giving citizens back control of
technology.  Well, we
aspire to public policies that
think in terms of cyber ISPs rather
than cyberwarfare.  Éc Filiol, can
you... I believe that
this cyber warfare council is
probably the biggest
intellectual scam of
recent years.  When I, I will
place myself on the purely
operational level, uh I think that the
cyber part, which is an
additional dimension at the end of the 20th century,
as aviation was at the
beginning of the 20th, will only play a
marginal role or support or preparation
in classic conflicts.  We must not
forget that war consists of taking
possession of very
material reality, whether it be territories,
resources and
also minds.  And we must not
forget that the ultimate goal of war is to
take
control of concrete realities.  So,
in my opinion, cybersecurity will remain marginal.  That doesn't
mean we should
relativize or
disdain it.  This is a reality that is unavoidable
.  But it doesn't have
the scope that people would like to attribute to it.  And
I agree that it's more to
legitimize, on the one hand,
pharaonic spending in the field,
but I believe that above all, more
than a cyber station, I believe that we are setting up cyber
dictatorships and developing.
Well, we realize that the
Prisme program, but
Prisme exists, has had precedents.
It turns out that there is still a
tendency for major democracies to
turn into digital police states.
What bothers me about
recent developments is that we are replacing the
presumption of innocence with the
presumption of guilt.  when you
spy on everyone by
default, not just
phone communications, because you have
proven contact with Corsican terrorists
or Islamic terrorists.  Uh, when
you're constantly spying, uh, I
mean less in gestures, you have to know
that with the connected internet and especially
outdoor CP, that is to say, from
outside, it's possible to know what's
happening in your house, your
electricity consumption, and the
mathematical processing tools of the
formation will allow it.  When
people are constantly and intimately spied on, it is because
they are assumed to be guilty
by default or
likely to commit acts.  We
cannot have a strong state; a state
must be strong but without trusting
its citizens, without letting them be free and
without respecting them.  And if we distrust
citizens, citizens will distrust
the state, and we will have a made-up state.
Recently, a Belgian cryptographer
announced that he himself
had been hacked by the NSA, "poudred" in
the jargon.  What do you
think?  Well, what surprises me is that
it still surprises
people.  Well, that makes sense.  In addition, this
Belgian cryptographer is well known for
having had sensitive mathematical activities
.  He is also someone who, at
one time, did not want to go
in the direction of controlling
cryptography.  particularly academic circles
in the United States.  So quite
simply, he is someone who matters
in the field who has had a
top-notch scientific output
, who also had some which was
plundered at the time since it should be noted
that he had done with another
French cryptologist Guillou, the famous
Guill squatter protocol which was plundered
by an American company in
direct violation of patents.  Except that with
three French lawyers against 50
American lawyers, the case was quickly
decided.  So it's not surprising that he
was being spied on.  But again, what surprises me is that this
still surprises people.  What
can you tell us a little bit
about the ability that people themselves,
the ordinary individual, have to protect themselves from
this kind of looting and infiltration
into their system
?  There are two separate things.  Uh,
targeted surveillance and
mass surveillance.  Um, I hope the
next Snowden revelations will
show us, on the one hand, how we can
go from one to the other.  Doesn't
simply not using Facebook,
Google, or Apple immediately put you
in the category of
targeted surveillance, whether you
use free software or not?
And that makes you a potential
terrorist.  But we still need to
distinguish between the two.
Targeted surveillance, as we see with the
latest revelations about
hardware implants and other toys of
the NSA, we already knew we cannot
escape it.  Well, that's a
fact.  Targeted surveillance is
legitimate when it is overseen by the
judicial authority, when there is
citizen and
democratic feedback control of the actions of the services
that practice it.  What is
truly intolerable is
mass surveillance.  As
Eric Fillol said, it's the presumption of
guilt.
These are massive violations of our
individual freedoms which cannot in
any way respect the principle of
proportionality.  However, this
mass surveillance, a priori, can be avoided.
Do you agree with
Eric Filiol on the cyber-dictatorship of a
government or governments that are
starting to fear their own
citizens and are beginning to
monitor their entire population
?  It is clear that the NSA's doctrine is that since
the enemy is by
definition located in the rest of the world, we will
spy on the rest of the world in order to have
subsequently spied on our enemies.   This is
a doctrine that is a
form of state paranoia, and that is
obviously a problem.  The fact is
that today we can probably
escape this mass surveillance
and that is the challenge today, it is to
increase the cost of this
surveillance or to try to make it
inoperative through our actions.  The
difference from the classic processes
in which
intelligence or the army intervened, so it was
often army against army, state against
state, here the vast majority of
actors are the citizens.  And
uh you talk about citizens, you talk
about citizens, you come from a
conference you led at
Sciencespo, did you find
the students sensitive to this type of
new values, this type of threat
?  Do you think they were
behind the times in terms of the perception
that the hacker community might have
about cybersecurity,
mass surveillance techniques, and that sort
of thing?  Do you think the
new generation is ready to resist
or is ready to find new
tools to escape this type
of surveillance?  I don't know if an
hour with a class of master's students from
Sciences Po is a
representative sample.  One thing I'm
sure of is that in the last 10 days,
five
people have come to me saying,
"Hey, you know what? I
left Facebook, and many of them told me it was because of
a conversation we had
in
recent months. I've seen dozens of
journalists using OT
or JPG to encrypt their
communications, and 100% of the
journalists I've spoken to about
protecting their sources have
replied, 'Oh yeah, that's right, we have a
problem here.'" Eric Philiol. Eric Filiol.
Jeremy is talking about encryption for source
protection. What
can you tell us as an expert
with your expertise as a
cryptographer? Are
journalists safe? Well, it's certainly
better than
communicating in plain text. It complicates things
, it complicates matters.
Now, he  We have to, I think we have to,
not kid ourselves, that most
encryption standards are
American-based and that
American subtlety has been a case of "putting all the
eggs in one basket." They haven't
put all the vulnerabilities in the
same place. What bothers me is that
the entire planet uses
American-based algorithms and
only
those. I saw a manufacturer, which I won't
name, that had chosen a
non-American encryption algorithm
and when it was bought
by an American company, it was
forced to switch. So the problem
is that we're leaving the United
States with a monopoly on all
standardization. I dispute the
fact that the Americans define the
global cryptographic standard. I think there are
very good cryptologists in
France, there are plenty of them all over Europe.
Why should we outsource our
security and
encryption standards to the Americans? Do
you think this is a surrender by
the French state? Not just that.  The
French state, of all the G8 and
G20 countries. It's certainly all the more surprising in France, and one can hardly
call it
scandalous, given that we are
preeminent nations in cryptology.
We have the École Normale Supérieure, which
produces extremely
brilliant minds. The problem is that for
a place on a program committee at an
American conference
controlled by the NSA, well, unfortunately, they're playing into the hands of the
United States. We
have a capacity to react, we
have a capacity to resist, we
have French ingenuity. We mustn't
forget that. We can't outsource our
security. In any case, we'll never achieve
security if we use the methods,
standards, and tools of our adversary.
Jammerman wanted to jump in. I don't like to
talk about sovereignty per se
because, well, the concept of the
nation-state isn't what motivates me
the most or defines me the most.
But here, there's something truly blatant
about seeing the sovereignty of a
third-party state... uh, no  Not only in respect of
the sovereignty of other states, but
also of the sovereignty of individuals,
of our informational sovereignty.
So, there is
clearly an opportunity for
public policies to try to reverse
this trend. And the only way
to do that, I am convinced, is
to put technology back in the hands of
citizens. Citizens need to
understand the importance of
privacy to understand the value of
cryptography, to understand how to
manage encryption keys, and to
eventually be in a position to
choose their encryption software or
their algorithm. When you
generate a fg, you can choose between
several algorithms. Well, I
feel that it is essential
today to raise the level of
awareness of individuals on the one hand, and on the other hand, that we
need
public policies, industrial policies
to promote these technologies
that are not in the hands of the NSA, which
obviously rely on
free software, decentralized architectures,
and encryption, period. The final word
, Éric Fillol.
What I, what  What scares me is that
we saw in '95 how
quickly we could switch from a
democratic to a non-
democratic government.
When you put in place
infrastructure, when you
potentially implement
surveillance tools—I'm thinking of Adopi, it seems like
Odin, but Adopi can allow
someone not only to know that
downloading content is
potentially illegal, but also to know
that you're interested in African art,
Jewish art, which is perfectly
legitimate. Tomorrow, this is a
permanent risk, and I was surprised to
see that the SPR (Special Protection and Protection) situations were
n't aware of this. This risk
is permanent. We could very well
switch to a much less
democratic regime with nauseating values
. And I think
recent events have shown once again that we're
not so far from that. What
scares me is that everything
we put in place—my fear—has been
legitimately used by precisely these
less democratic governments if they were to
come to power.  in power and could, well,
automate a genocide or automate
mass arrests. And that's what
scares me. As long as we're in a
democratic state, I think I want to do the right thing,
I want to trust
our governments. Eric Filal, Jérémie
Zimmerman. Perhaps one last word
? Yes. As long as these states remain
democratic. Jérémie, one last word for sure.
When we talk about protecting
privacy, we're talking about a freedom that's more
fundamental than others because it
allows the exercise of other
freedoms, and this privacy is, above
all, our intimacies.
Our intimacies are a space in which
we aren't judged, in which we
share trust, and in which we
can experiment, in which we can
invent new ideas, new
concepts, in which we can be
ourselves. This privacy, this
intimacy, is our identity. It's what
defines us as human beings.
And that's what's at stake.  I believe,
through this imperative, that we must
regain control of technology.
It's about regaining control of
technology to regain control
of our humanity. On the contrary,
letting ourselves be controlled by the machine.
Charerman, thank you Éric Filiol, thank you.
Illiteracy today is
code. If you don't know how to code, you're
illiterate. Just as there were
many illiterate people in 18th-century
France. A web illiterate. Uh, you're an
literate, truly illiterate. It's because you
haven't coded. It's about as much of a
handicap for the world that's coming
your way as not knowing how to read in the
18th century. Will the American economy
continue to grow slowly? I
would say it's likely, and their
main handicap is finance. We
can no longer talk about the weight of
French diplomatic influence in the Middle East.
It no longer exists. It's
American influence. They have become
the voice of American influence.
[Music]